En varios videos hemos hablado sobre la Ley de
los gases ideales, que nos dice que la presión
multiplicada por el volumen será igual al número
de moles por la constante de los gases ideales
multiplicada por la temperatura medida en Kelvin.
Ahora, en todos nuestros estudios sobre la Ley de
los gases ideales suponemos que los gases con los
que estamos tratando son ideales. Y ahora vamos
a pensar un poco sobre qué significa ser ideal y
en qué se diferencian de los gases reales. Bueno,
para que podamos suponer que un gas es ideal
suponemos que su volumen, el volumen del gas,
es insignificante en relación con el contenedor;
la otra cosa que suponemos es que las moléculas
del gas no interactúan entre sí, las moléculas no
interactúan. Ahora, en el mundo real sabemos que
todas las moléculas ocupan algo de volumen, pero
podría ser una suposición razonable si estamos
hablando de un contenedor realmente grande, y no
tenemos una densidad de moléculas tan alta. Es
razonable suponer que el volumen del gas en sí
mismo, o que las moléculas en sí mismas tienen
un volumen pequeño colectivamente en relación
con el contenedor, y es razonable en muchas
circunstancias suponer que las moléculas
no interactúan, tal vez no tienen fuerzas
intermoleculares fuertes, una vez más porque
ocupan una pequeña porción del volumen, e incluso
podrían no acercarse entre sí con demasiada
frecuencia. Y es por eso que estos son supuestos
razonables y nos permiten decir que PV = nRT, que
es una aproximación valiosa en la mayoría de las
circunstancias. Pero en el mundo real sabemos
que cada molécula ocupa algo del volumen y que
si sumamos todas las moléculas juntas por supuesto
que ocupan algo del volumen. Y si hay suficientes
moléculas o si el contenedor es lo suficientemente
pequeño, sabemos que el volumen del gas en
relación con el contenedor no será insignificante.
También sabemos que las moléculas van a
interactuar entre sí de alguna manera o forma.
Dos moléculas no pueden ocupar el mismo espacio al
mismo tiempo, por lo que definitivamente existen
algunas fuerzas repulsivas e incluso para algunas
moléculas bastante inertes se pueden formar
algunos dipolos temporales que tengan alguna
atracción temporal o repulsión temporal. Entonces,
si se trata de una situación en la que las cosas
son menos ideales, y voy a hacer un ejemplo
donde las moléculas están ocupando un volumen
significativo en relación con el contenedor, no
se puede decir que el volumen de las moléculas
sea insignificante en relación con el contenedor
y suponemos que están interactuando entre sí.
Definitivamente se van a repeler, no pueden ocupar
el mismo espacio al mismo tiempo, pero pueden
atraerse en algunos puntos o rechazarse en otros
puntos. Por lo que, en esta situación, donde no
podemos hacer estas suposiciones, tendremos
que modificar la Ley de los gases ideales.